[Music]
hello how are you I'm diego luna and I'm
here with youtube about to show you
my 10 essential objects
plus
my grandfather was a photographer and he had
a bunch of cameras a collection of
cameras and then when my
grandfather died my father and I went  then the
distribution of things and we stayed with
the photography equipment and we set up a
dark room in my case I would have been about
13 years old I think and I learned
photography I would do developed and now
also with digital it is a temptation and
the phones that are already cameras  and they are
everything so it is good to
return to photography that has to
do with well yes with all that process that
does not happen automatically no that requires you to
think about what is the best way to
photograph a moment an objective a
person
[Music] it
is a sauce  of habanero the truth is
that I always always have some type of
sauce the habanero is great because it is
definitive the habanero bites bastard and there is
no doubt that this one that you
throw it on
and  also because when you travel,
especially in these promotions that
are moving from one place to another and you
generally eat in hotels and everything
turns out a bit the same and also the jamaicón syndrome or the sadness of home persists, it makes you
want the  things bite and then they don't
bite or you get drunk and you
can't have something typical or in the morning
so if a sauce is always
good josé well I have a daughter and a son
is that
I can steal their things this is
horn is from  my daughter
and I brought her on the trip because that's
why I don't like to listen to music with
headphones I feel that I also lose
my relationship with him with the outside world, not the
possibility of realizing that something else
is happening and well, nothing that I steal from him  Its
his horn to my daughter who will return
intact, don't worry, Magnani,
well, every time I turn on this horn or
every time I use it, I remember my
daughter and when I had to steal
my son's horn, it's similar
this time.  a
note ranchero
music
don't notice that I think I think that
almost this is a very very dry very cold guy he
's from ranchera music he wouldn't
stand it he wouldn't stand it
I think he prefers the instrumental at
all times not for fear of
breaking  not for fear of breaking he
has to keep his composure I tell you
that he is a spy this is not a guy
who has time
to get into the feeling
and I really like to cook so traveling
with his knives is important not with
this thing that  Everyone travels
and stays at other people's houses,
whether they lend it to you or they
rent it to you, whether you get it through an application
and there is the least interaction,
but generally you already arrive at
someone's space and arrive at the spa at
Someone's kitchen is always very intimate and it
's probably
disappointing
because everyone cooks the way they
like and that's very specific, so
when I travel and go into a kitchen I
like to come with c  with a knife
that I feel comfortable with
and which is that it reminds me of how I like
to cook and also that allows me to
feel at home quickly
[Music]
this one in particular comes from well it comes
from being here in new york is the
story of  a
restaurant in new york run
by
a chef who serves italian cuisine
here in new york i was going to go to italy
and i was going to come here doing this
tour promoting andor and i wanted to read
something that had to do with
spaces and  the places I was going to
go more like the places I was going to
go and about cooking
and a friend
a friend in Spain recommended me she
recommended this book and it's incredible
because it hit the nail on the head so the perfect one
is what I wanted  read this right
now
this is a pill box let's see let's see
what's in here
[Music]
and inside vitamin c very
important vitamin d as a result of the pandemic it
turned out that we have to take one daily
and I didn't know these are the vitamins
what the p  Well, yes, they accompany me every
day and I say these in particular because
I never forget them, as I always do,
so it is true that in this little box in
the bag, I don't know, practically
two or three weeks
and now that I take it out, I promise to
take it  Bad,
well, this is one, it's a mask,
a face mask, however they want to
say it, and it's made of cloth and now it always accompanies me
because if something worries me, it's
that
now we put on the mask for
any reason, all of them disposable, and
where will these masks end up?
I'm really worried about nothing, a
mask, a mask with a cloth mask,
and it's richer
[Music]
I suppose there are many people who don't
even recognize these objects anymore,
this is a pencil, they were used long before, and
this is a pen, everyone used to
bring a pen with cinema today you go out into the
street and ask for a pen
probably two out of ten will tell you
if I bring one and they will be like
writers my age or even older
big I like to always bring a
pen fiction in my backpack and it
reminds me that I am from another generation
basically what I have here I would not like it to
be among my ten essential objects
but there is no way to travel and be
in a promotion  if you don't travel with all
this
cables of all kinds because the
technology companies have not reached an
agreement or rather do not have the
intention of reaching an agreement and that
there is a cable that works for everything if
you have a telephone of a brand it is
If you have one from another brand, this is
within the same brand. If you
change the telephone, change the cable, the plugs
so that they work in Europe, in England,
in the United States, in the United States, and Mexico, when it has
this little beak that I don't understand why
sometimes it has it and sometimes  sometimes it doesn't have
it anyway it's a disaster we have become
slaves
to the cables and plugs that we
have to have for our devices to
work
[Music]
that is, well, a notebook I guess it's  It's
like a reflection of your mind of
how your mind works
but not a notebook
I usually always start like this with this it's going to be the
notebook for this project and after a while
there's a recipe and a phone number an
east address suddenly he grabs  my
son my daughter and they opposed drawing
but that is that chaos I like in a
notebook there you have to
rethink things you write something in the
immediacy of a moment and then if you
want to share it then you have to
transcribe it and transcribe it  This is an
opportunity to
improve
it. Thank you all for
listening to us nonsense that is very good
[Music]